Good evening.
"Yeah"
"Yes, mom doesn't change Shit in me."
"Bye."
" 익λα Hey, meet up."
"I got a weird knee sign."
"Yes, mommy has a weird Şeyia to be good."
"Yes, mommy has a weird feeling."
"I remember there was a tree in the old place."
"I forgot to go to the old place."
"Oh, yes."
"The old place in the old place is really small."
"I was a little old when I was there."
"Hot? I remember there was a mall that was like a mall."
"There was a Lego house."
"Morl like that?"
"Yes, there were lots of outlets and Lego house."
"And there were a car to rent."
"Oh, that's where it was."
"Print Hotel?" "It's different."
"Who?"
"Oh, yes, Prince Hotel is near the neighborhood."
"Yes, Prince Hotel is near the neighborhood."